You know how it's been. In the Midwest, temperatures have been lower than at the South Pole. In Alabama, kids slept in schools. Highways shut down in Florida and Louisiana 'cause of ice.
你知道情况一直是怎么样的。在中西部地区，气温比南极还低。在阿拉巴马州，孩子们睡在学校里。在佛罗里达州和路易斯安那州，由于结冰，高速公路被迫关闭。
Drivers in Atlanta ditched their cars and slept inside grocery stores. And in Southern California, it was just lovely.
亚特兰大的司机们丢弃了他们的车，睡在杂货店里。而在南加州，天气却非常宜人。
[OCEAN WAVES]
[海浪声]
Look at this! This is January! It's like 80! It's beautiful!
看看这个！现在可是1月！气温有80华氏度（约27摄氏度）！太美了！
Sharon Jacobucci moved here from New York City years ago specifically to escape the cold. And she does not understand why the rest of us have not moved.
莎伦·雅各布奇几年前从纽约市搬到这里，专门为了躲避寒冷。她不明白为什么我们其他人还没搬过来。
She has a job which puts her next to the beach all day long. A job that frankly, does not sound like a fun job. She gives out parking tickets. She's a meter maid. But 'cause it's on the beach, it makes her very, very happy.
她有一份工作，让她整天待在海滩边。坦白说，这份工作听起来并不好玩。她负责开罚单。她是个贴罚单的。但因为是在海滩上，这让她感到非常、非常快乐。
I work all of Venice Beach. Villa Marina all the way to Navy Street.
我负责整个威尼斯海滩。从玛丽娜别墅一直到海军街。
And I write tickets. I impound vehicles. I hug people. I say hello. I socialize.
我写罚单。我扣押车辆。我拥抱人们。我打招呼。我进行社交。
I write more tickets. I impound vehicles. I answer radio call, and hug people some more.
我写更多的罚单。我扣押车辆。我回复电台呼叫，然后再多拥抱一些人。
I work at the beach and get paid to go to the beach! You can't beat it!
我在海滩工作，还能领着工资去海滩！没法比这更好的了！
Sharon was saying all this to one of our producers, Ben Calhoun. They were looking out onto the sand.
莎伦在对我们的一位制片人本·卡尔霍恩说这一切。他们正眺望着沙滩。
I like it. And the water. Look at that water! Look at the sand!
我喜欢它。还有水。看看那海水！看看那沙子！
It's very therapeutic, especially when you're writing tickets. Sometimes you just go stand out there and you look and you go, God is good.
这非常有疗愈感，尤其是在你写罚单的时候。有时你只是站在那儿，看着它，然后你会想，上帝真是仁慈。
What do you feel when you look out that way? Out to the beach?
当你朝那边看的时候，你有什么感觉？看向海滩那边？
What cute guy is out there? [LAUGHS] What cute guy is out there!
那边有什么帅哥吗？[笑声] 那边有什么帅哥！
What do you want me to say? I'm looking at the men! We're at the beach! What else would I be looking at at the beach? [LAUGHS]
你想让我说什么？我正在看男人！我们在海滩上！在海滩上我还能看什么？[笑声]
And right then, right on cue, maybe 10 feet away, a young surfer starts taking off his wetsuit.
就在那时，说来就来，大概10英尺外，一位年轻的冲浪者开始脱下他的潜水服。
Just look at that! I get to watch the men strip! Look at him over there! Come on, honey! This is a great gig! [LAUGHS]
看看那个！我能看着男人脱衣服！看他那边！来吧，亲爱的！这真是份好差事！[笑声]
Sharon lives five blocks from the beach. She told Ben that she knows everybody on Venice Beach. And then he walked with her on her rounds and it was like total love fest, nonstop greetings, blowing kisses.
莎伦住在离海滩五个街区远的地方。她告诉本，她认识威尼斯海滩上的每一个人。然后他和她一起巡逻，感觉就像一场永不停歇的爱之庆典，不断的问候，飞吻。
[KISSING SOUNDS]
[接吻声]
Don't listen to a word she says!
别听她说的半个字！
I love you, baby. My honey bunny.
我爱你，宝贝。我的小甜心。
Morning, baby!
早上好，宝贝！
Good morning, baby! How are you?
早上好，宝贝！你好吗？
Fabulous. How  are you?
棒极了。你呢？
All right, darlin'.
还可以，亲爱的。
You do know everybody.
你确实认识每一个人。
I just told you that.
我刚才就告诉你了。
Have you been watching the weather the last month or so with what's been going on in the rest of the country?
你有没有关注过去一个月左右全国其他地区的天气情况？
I think nothing of it, baby. 'Cause I'm enjoying my sunshiny view in Venice.
我对此一点也不关心，宝贝。因为我正在享受我在威尼斯的阳光美景。
I don't think anything about it. Could care less. That's why I moved here.
我对此一点想法都没有。根本不在乎。这就是我搬到这里的原因。
If they don't like that, move your butts to Venice. Come to California. Hell, even go to Florida!
如果他们不喜欢那样，就把你们的屁股挪到威尼斯来。来加州。见鬼，甚至去佛罗里达也行！
That's your message to them?
这就是你要传达给他们的信息？
Yes! Pack your bags and move! Come to California! Come somewhere sunshiny beautiful!
是的！打包行李搬过来！来加州！来一些阳光明媚美丽的地方！
Well, there's a lot of sympathy for you. Today on our radio show, we thought it would just be nice as we shiver, as we take our dogs for long walks in freezing temperatures, as we feel cold air leak in the windows and seep under our skins, we just thought it would be nice to get away from all that. For all of us who cannot take Sharon's advice and move to Venice Beach right this second, we can at least spend one hour thinking about places where it's warm. We can use the power of the radio to have a midwinter beach visit.
好吧，大家都很同情你。今天在我们的广播节目中，我们想，当我们瑟瑟发抖，当我们带着狗在零下的温度中长距离散步，当我们感觉到冷空气从窗户缝渗入并刺入我们的皮肤时，想这些确实会很好。对于我们所有无法听从莎伦的建议立刻搬到威尼斯海滩的人，我们至少可以花一小时思考温暖的地方。我们可以利用广播的力量来进行一次隆冬的海滩之旅。
And so today on our radio show, let's just get away. Let's all get away. Let's go to the beach.
所以今天在我们的广播节目中，让我们放松一下。让我们所有人都放松一下。让我们去海滩吧。
Friends, at Huntington and Malibu, they're shooting the pier. At Rincon, they're walking the nose. They're going on safari on the islands this year. So if you're coming, get ready to go.
朋友们，在亨廷顿和马里布，他们正在冲浪。在林孔，他们正在练习脚尖冲浪。他们今年要去岛上探险。所以如果你要来，准备好出发吧。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. David Sedaris later this hour. Stay with us.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台发行。大卫·塞达里斯稍后会在本小时内出现。请继续收听。
[MUSIC - "KING OF THE BEACH" BY WAVVES]
[音乐 - WAVVES乐队的《海滩之王》]
Act One, "Mexican Beach Doctor."
第一幕，“墨西哥海滩医生”。
Oh hello? Yep, I'm here now.
哦，喂？是的，我现在在这儿。
Hey, Alex.
嘿，亚历克斯。
Hello, little buddy. How are you?
你好，小伙计。你好吗？
[LAUGHS] Hi, other little buddy.
[笑声] 嗨，另一个小伙计。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
This first story takes place on a very warm beach in Mexico. Shane DuBow told it to our producer Alex Blumberg. They're old friends.
第一个故事发生在一个墨西哥非常温暖的海滩上。谢恩·杜鲍告诉了我们的制片人亚历克斯·布隆伯格。他们是老朋友。
And as we were putting together this week's program, Alex remembered this thing that happened to Shane decades ago when Shane was on a kayaking trip in Mexico down in Baja California. Shane and his friends took a month long vacation. And every day, they would head out into the Gulf of California and go sea kayaking. They were really kind of in the middle of nowhere.
当我们整理本周节目时，亚历克斯想起了几十年前谢恩在墨西哥下加利福尼亚州进行皮划艇旅行时发生的这件事。谢恩和他的朋友们休了一个月的假。每天，他们都会前往加利福尼亚湾进行海上皮划艇。他们基本上处于荒无人烟的地方。
There's little beach communities and some little tourist centers. But mostly what we were doing was finding deserted open beaches and camping. So there was nobody around for most of the time.
有一些小的海滩社区和一些小的旅游中心。但我们大部分时间是在寻找荒凉的开放海滩并露营。所以大部分时间周围都没有人。
Wow. So it was just you--and there was how many of them was it you said? Seven? Six, seven?
哇。所以只有你们——你说有多少人？七个？六个，七个？
There was six or seven. And some people might go fishing, some people might play cards, some people might snorkel. I think we slept outside a lot.
有六或七个。有些人可能会去钓鱼，有些人可能会打牌，有些人可能会浮潜。我想我们经常睡在户外。
It felt like we were 12 years old pretending to be Robinson Crusoe, living off the land. So we carried all our own water, all our own food, camping supplies, tents, sleeping bags, cooking supplies.
感觉我们就像12岁的孩子假装自己是鲁滨逊·克鲁索，靠土地为生。所以我们携带了自己所有的水、所有的食物、露营用品、帐篷、睡袋、烹饪用品。
Sunscreen, I hope.
我希望带了防晒霜。
Sunscreen? No, we were young then. We just figured it'd be fine.
防晒霜？不，那时我们还年轻。我们只是觉得会没事的。
[LAUGHING] Are you serious? You didn't bring any sunscreen?
[笑声] 你是认真的吗？你们没带任何防晒霜？
I'm sure I didn't.
我肯定没带。
So we're in Baja. We are on a layover, which means we are just camped somewhere. We're not trying to kayak right now. And we've been clamming all day.
所以我们在下加利福尼亚州。我们在中途停留，这意味着我们只是在某个地方露营。我们现在不打算划皮划艇。我们整天都在挖蛤蜊。
And my neck locks up and I can't turn my head to one side. And this is bad for lots of reasons. But when you're kayaking, you have to be able to paddle. You have to be able to use both arms.
然后我的脖子锁住了，我无法把头转向一边。这在很多方面都很糟糕。但当你划皮划艇时，你必须能够划桨。你必须能够使用双臂。
And this neck locking up, this is something that's happened to you periodically throughout your life.
脖子锁住，这是你一生中周期性发生的事情。
Yeah. This happens six to eight times a year.
是的。这每年发生六到八次。
OK.
好的。
It usually lasts three or four days.
它通常持续三到四天。
Right.
对。
But so no one wants to be stuck on the beach while I'm working out my neck for three or four days. So we had run into a little ex-pat community on a beach pretty close to where we were camping. These folks were living in campers and had set up little cantinas, which were really just stakes with a tarp over them and they would serve beers. Or in our case, they showed us how to clam and then they made us a clam feast.
但没有人想在海滩上被困住，而我在那里修复我的脖子三到四天。所以我们偶然发现了一个离我们露营地很近的海滩上的小外籍社区。这些人住在露营车里，并搭建了小餐馆，实际上只是用防水布盖着的木桩，他们会供应啤酒。或者就我们的情况而言，他们向我们展示了如何挖蛤蜊，然后为我们做了一顿蛤蜊盛宴。
So we went back to the guy that had shown us how to do that, to his camper on the beach. And I said, there's not any chiropractors anywhere nearby? Which was just a ridiculous question, 'cause there was nothing nearby.
所以我们回到那个教我们的人那里，回到他在海滩上的露营车。我说，附近没有脊椎按摩师吗？这是一个荒谬的问题，因为附近什么都没有。
Right.
对。
And I mean, this is where it kind of gets apocryphal, but is actually true. 'Cause he gets this wistful look in his eye, and he says, no, there's no chiropractor. But there is an amateur chiropractor who helps some of the local people. And his name is Johnny Tequila.
我的意思是，这在某种程度上变成了杜撰，但实际上是真的。因为他的眼睛里露出了向往的神情，他说，没有，没有脊椎按摩师。但有一个业余脊椎按摩师，他帮助过一些当地人。他的名字叫强尼·龙舌兰。
[LAUGHING]
[笑声]
And he lives on a boat two coves over from where you're staying. And if you go to this man, he may help you.
他住在离你们住的地方隔两个海湾的一条船上。如果你去找这个人，他可能会帮助你。
[LAUGHING]
[笑声]
It was very mystical.
这非常神秘。
Right. And you were like, well, you had me at amateur chiropractor.
对。而你当时的反应是，好吧，你用“业余脊椎按摩师”就把我吸引住了。
[LAUGHING]
[笑声]
But once I find out that his name is Dr. Johnny Tequila--
但当我发现他的名字叫强尼·龙舌兰博士时——
[LAUGHING]
[笑声]
So you said, how do you get there?
所以你问，怎么到那儿？
How do I get there? I was like, I don't want to miss it. And he's like, you won't miss it. I was like, well, tell me where it is.
怎么到那儿？我就想，我不想错过它。他说，你不会错过的。我说，告诉我它在哪儿。
And so he grabs a bar napkin and in black ballpoint pen I think, sketches me a rough outline of the coast, and puts an X. There's an X marks the spot. That's where Johnny Tequila is, two coves over. No one wants to go with me. They're all gonna chill out, play cards.
于是他抓起一张酒吧餐巾纸，我想用黑色圆珠笔，给我画了一个粗略的海岸轮廓，并画了一个X。X标记了位置。那就是强尼·龙舌兰所在的地方，隔两个海湾。没人想跟我一起去。他们都想放松一下，打打牌。
Oh, so you had to kayak up to this guy.
哦，所以你不得不划皮划艇去找这个家伙。
Yes. So I have to kayak to him.
是的。所以我得划皮划艇去找他。
I see.
我明白了。
And my friends had taken to teasing me about my paddle stroke, which was at this point one-armed and half crippled. And they were calling it the chicken wing.
我的朋友们开始嘲笑我的划桨动作，当时是一只手划，半残废状态。他们称之为“鸡翅膀”。
'Cause of your neck?
因为你的脖子？
'Cause of my neck.
因为我的脖子。
Yeah.
对。
So I chicken wing for two coves worth. Maybe a mile paddle. And you're really close to the shore, and the beach is right on your right and the open ocean is on your left. And you're chicken winging.
所以我划了两个海湾的“鸡翅膀”。可能有一英里的路程。你离岸边非常近，右边是海滩，左边是广阔的海洋。而你在划“鸡翅膀”。
One cove, OK. And I'm looking at my-- and my napkin gets wet, so my map gets all destroyed, comes apart.
一个海湾，好的。我看着我的——我的餐巾纸湿了，所以地图全毁了，散开了。
[LAUGHING] 'Cause the water's running down your paddle handle?
[笑声] 因为水顺着你的桨柄流下来了？
So I chicken wing on over. And there in the second cove, is a catamaran in the middle of an empty cove.
所以我划着“鸡翅膀”过去了。在第二个海湾里，有一个双体船停在空旷的海湾中间。
And I don't want you to get the idea that this is a harbor or a dock or anything man made. Nothing around. And it's docked in the water maybe 20 or 30 yards from shore. And as I paddle closer, I don't see anyone.
我不希望你认为这是一个港口、码头或任何人工建筑。周围什么都没有。它停在离岸边大概20或30码的水里。当我划近时，我没看到任何人。
Mm hmm.
嗯嗯。
It's got a cabin. But the mast is up, no sail is up. And as I get closer and closer, I can see around the mast, lined up, are empty Cuervo Gold tequila bottles.
它有一个船舱。但桅杆是竖着的，没有帆。当我越来越近时，我可以看到桅杆周围，排成一排的是空的夸尔沃金牌龙舌兰酒瓶。
[LAUGHING]
[笑声]
But kind of orderly. That was the weird thing. Usually you don't associate empty tequila bottles with order. But these had been meticulously lined up.
但排列得挺整齐。这很奇怪。通常你不会把空龙舌兰酒瓶和秩序联系起来。但这些都被精心排列好了。
Ringing the mast.
围绕着桅杆。
Ringing the mast. And again, I'm paddling up on a boat in the middle of nowhere with no one else around. And I don't really know how to even start. And from some deep place, the word that comes to me is ahoy.
围绕着桅杆。再说一次，我划船靠近一个身处荒郊野外的船，周围没有其他人。我甚至不知道该怎么开始。从内心深处，我蹦出的一个词是“船上的人！”。
[LAUGHING]
[笑声]
[LAUGHING] Which I've certainly never used in normal conversation. So I say, ahoy!
[笑声] 我在正常交谈中肯定从没用过这个词。所以我喊道，船上的人！
And from out of the cabin comes a completely naked woman. She looks American. Blond hair, tanned so deeply, it's like the tan that goes to your liver. It's just tan all the way through.
然后从船舱里走出来一个完全赤裸的女人。她看起来像个美国人。金色的头发，晒得非常深，那种晒到了肝脏的颜色。就是完全晒透了。
Really muscly. Her shoulders looked like she was probably a rafting guide in Colorado. So she's completely naked and completely unphased about being completely naked. Just greets me and talks to me as if she wearing clothes. And she's above me, so I'm just looking up at her being naked from my kayak holding on to the side of their boat.
非常健壮。她的肩膀看起来像是科罗拉多州的漂流向导。所以她完全赤裸，并且对赤裸这件事完全无动于衷。就像她穿着衣服一样跟我打招呼和交谈。她在我上方，所以我就从我的皮划艇里仰视着她赤裸的样子，扶着她们船的侧面。
And I'm in my kayak and I said, is Johnny Tequila here? And she's very nice, and she goes, no, he went to town for supplies. But he'll be back shortly. Why don't you wait until he comes back?
我在我的皮划艇里，我说，强尼·龙舌兰在这儿吗？她非常友善，她说，不，他进城去拿物资了。但他很快就会回来。你为什么不等他回来呢？
And then eventually Johnny Tequila, we see him on the beach near us. And he's got a little rowboat and he rows back to us.
然后最后强尼·龙舌兰，我们在附近的沙滩上看到了他。他有一条小划艇，然后划船回到我们这里。
And he looks exactly like her. I mean, he's got on shorts, but he's got that tan. He looks kind of muscly in his shoulders and chest, and they both have wild, bleached out blond hair and real scruffy.
他看起来和她一模一样。我的意思是，他穿着短裤，但他有那种晒痕。他的肩膀和胸部看起来很健壮，他们俩都有野性、漂白的金发，而且看起来很邋遢。
Maybe 30s? Although the sun makes everyone look older, so who knows? And I tell him my story and he's like, yeah of course I'll perform some amateur chiropractory on your neck.
大概30多岁？虽然太阳让每个人看起来都更老，谁知道呢？我告诉他我的故事，他说，是的，当然我会对你的脖子进行一些业余脊椎按摩。
He didn't say that. He said just yeah, of course I'll help you. Follow me to shore.
他没那么说。他说只是是的，当然我会帮你。跟我到岸上去。
So he rows and I chicken wing to the shore, and we pull our boats up. And then he said, follow me.
于是他划船，我划着“鸡翅膀”到岸边，我们把船拉上来。然后他说，跟着我。
And now we are going-- I want to say jungle, but it was not jungle. But it's dense scrub. I mean, there's bushes all around us, there's cacti. Winding around in the middle of Mexico with no one else for miles, and I'm following him on this path, a really faint path.
现在我们要去——我想说丛林，但这根本不是丛林。但那是茂密的灌木丛。我的意思是，我们周围都是灌木，有仙人掌。在墨西哥中部没人住的地方绕来绕去，我跟着他走在这一条小路上，一条非常模糊的小路。
And we come to a clearing. And in the clearing, there is a table exactly like a massage table or a chiropractic table you'd see in a real chiropractor's office.
我们来到一块空地。在那块空地上，有一张桌子，和你会在真正的脊椎按摩师诊所看到的按摩桌或脊椎按摩桌一模一样。
With the center part that's open and you could put your face down there. And the neck part articulates and comes up. You know, it's the real deal. And a life size human skeleton hanging from a tree. Which I assume is a replica. But it looks like it.
中间部分是空的，你可以把脸放下去。颈部部分可以活动并向上抬起。你知道，那是真家伙。还有一个人体骨架挂在树上。我想那是复制品。但看起来很像。
A skeleton and the table in a clearing in the middle of the desert in Mexico. And then has me lie on my back looking up at his face and his crazy hair. And he's shirtless. Did I tell you my chiropractor is shirtless? He's shirtless. And he puts his hands around my neck.
在墨西哥沙漠中央的空地上，一个骨架和一张桌子。然后他让我躺在背上，看着他的脸和他那疯狂的头发。他是赤膊的。我有没有告诉你我的脊椎按摩师是赤膊的？他是赤膊的。他把手放在我的脖子上。
In the middle of Mexico, in a clearing with a skeleton, my amateur chiropractor now has my neck in his hands. And he gives me a chiropractic exam that resembles every other chiropractic exam I've received. And then he does an adjustment that also passes as any other chiropractic adjustment I've received.
在墨西哥中部，在一个挂着骨架的空地上，我的业余脊椎按摩师现在把我的脖子放在了他的手里。他给我做了一次脊椎按摩检查，就像我接受过的任何其他脊椎按摩检查一样。然后他做了一次调整，也和我在其他地方接受的任何脊椎按摩调整一样。
And I say, Johnny Tequila, thank you for adjusting my neck. Can I pay you?
我说，强尼·龙舌兰，谢谢你调整我的脖子。我可以付钱给你吗？
And he said, no. I just do this to help people. There will be no payment. But if you ever see me in a bar, you can buy me a shot of tequila.
他说，不。我这样做只是为了帮助别人。不会有任何报酬。但如果你在酒吧见到我，你可以请我喝一杯龙舌兰酒。
[LAUGHING] Then the next day, was in fact your neck better?
[笑声] 那么第二天，你的脖子真的好点了吗？
Well, it's possible I'm collapsing time. But the way I remember it, I chicken wing back and over the next few hours, I start to feel much, much better. And the neck is OK.
好吧，我可能把时间搞混了。但据我记忆，我划着“鸡翅膀”回去，在接下来的几个小时里，我开始感觉好多了。脖子也没事了。
Do you think that Johnny Tequila-- when you think of Johnny Tequila, is he an argument for chucking it all and moving to some quiet beach in some distant land or is he an argument against it?
你认为强尼·龙舌兰——当你想到强尼·龙舌兰时，他是为了抛弃一切搬到遥远土地上某个宁静的海滩提供了一个论据，还是反对它的论据？
He's 100% an argument for. I can't believe you asked me that question. A simpler life. Just crack people's necks, drink tequila, sing in the cantina, and go home to my naked lady.
他是100%赞成的论据。我不敢相信你问我那个问题。更简单的生活。只要帮人整整脖子，喝喝龙舌兰酒，在餐馆里唱唱歌，回家找我的赤裸女郎。
Did I not tell the story to make it seem good? It seemed great!
难道我没把这个故事讲得听起来很好吗？这看起来棒极了！
[LAUGHING]
[笑声]
Shane DuBow talking to Alex Blumberg in Chicago.
谢恩·杜鲍在芝加哥与亚历克斯·布隆伯格交谈。
[MUSIC - "JOHNNY" BY AB & THE SEA]
[音乐 - AB & THE SEA的《强尼》]
Act Two, "Long Talk on a Short Pier." Sam Mullins' friend Stesha was born in same month as he was, in the same hospital. Their moms were best friends.
第二幕，“短码头上的长谈”。萨姆·马林斯的朋友斯特莎和他出生在同一个月，在同一家医院。他们的妈妈是最好的朋友。
So of course, when they were little kids, they became best friends. You know those bathtub pictures that parents take of their kids? There are bathtub shots of Sam and Stesha back when they were little toddlers growing up in this town called Vernon in Canada.
所以当然，当他们是小孩子的时候，他们就成了最好的朋友。你知道父母给孩子拍的那些浴盆照片吗？有萨姆和斯特莎小时候在加拿大弗农这个小镇长大的浴盆照片。
Anyway, one day his best friend Stesha moves away. He's devastated, talks to her now and then. A couple of years pass, until one summer.
总之，有一天他最好的朋友斯特莎搬走了。他崩溃了，偶尔和她通通电话。几年过去了，直到一个夏天。
Sam told what happened that summer on stage at a storytelling event called "The Flame." It was the summer before he started high school, before he turned 13.
萨姆在一次名为“火焰”的故事讲述活动舞台上讲述了那个夏天发生的事情。那是他上高中之前，在他13岁之前。
Which is a really big summer. Because if you think about it, you need to prepare yourself to go from a building with finger paintings on the walls to go into a new building with anti-drug ads, and there's like condom dispensers in the bathrooms. And when you're sitting in the classroom looking out the window, instead of the familiar jungle gym with a slide, there's four guys wearing bandannas hot boxing in an Acura Integra.
这是一个非常重要的夏天。因为如果你仔细想想，你需要为自己做准备，从一栋墙上贴着手指画的建筑，去往一栋有反毒品广告的新建筑，而且厕所里有避孕套自动贩卖机。当你坐在教室里向窗外看时，看到的不是熟悉的有滑梯的攀爬架，而是四个戴着头巾的家伙在一辆讴歌Integra里吞云吐雾。
So my plan for the summer was pretty clear. I needed to get cool fast. I wanted to wear the right things, to think the right things, to do the right things. I wasn't even concerned about having my own unique style. That first year, I just wanted to walk in already the epitome of what a high school boy was.
所以那个夏天的计划很明确。我需要快速变得酷起来。我想穿对的衣服，想对的事，做对的事。我甚至不关心是否有自己独特的风格。第一年，我只是想走进去时就已经是一个高中男生的缩影。
So I went out and I bought a skateboard. And I was really bad at it, so I just carried it around with me everywhere. It was more of an accessory than anything.
所以我出去买了一个滑板。但我玩得很差，所以我只是把它随身携带。比起其他任何东西，它更像是一个配件。
And I started listening to some new music. And I was doing push ups and sit ups and learning some guitar. And I was learning how to handle my voice cracking. The secrets to not having your changing voice crack is to just not be excited or enthusiastic about anything, ever.
然后我开始听一些新音乐。我在做俯卧撑和仰卧起坐，学弹吉他。我在学习如何处理我变声时的声音。让变声期声音不破音的秘诀就是永远不要对任何事情感到兴奋或热情。
I needed to learn how to play it cool, so that I'd be ready to talk to girls. Pardon me. To talk to women. So it was in the middle of this get cool fast regimen when one day my mom burst in. And she's like, hey Stesha's on the phone! Pick it up!
我需要学习如何表现得酷，这样我就准备好和女孩交谈了。抱歉。和女人交谈。所以正是在这个“快速变酷”方案的过程中，有一天我妈妈冲了进来。她说，嘿，斯特莎在电话上！接电话！
So I pick it up and Stesha's like, hey Sammy! Guess what? I'm coming to visit for a few weeks, and I'm actually going to be in town for my birthday! And I was wondering, since I don't have a house in Vernon anymore, and since you live on the lake, I was thinking maybe I could have my birthday party at your house.
我接起电话，斯特莎说，嘿萨米！你猜怎么着？我要去拜访几个星期，而且生日那天我正好会在镇上！我在想，既然我在弗农已经没有房子了，而且既然你住在湖边，我在想也许我可以在你家举办生日派对。
And my mind was reeling. This was perfect. Because the best part of having a girl for a best friend is the birthday parties. At every one of Stesha's birthday parties growing up, I was always the only guy. And I used to act like it was a drag, but it was the best.
我的头脑在飞速运转。这太完美了。因为有一个女孩作为最好的朋友，最好的部分就是生日派对。在我成长的每一次斯特莎的生日派对上，我总是唯一的男人。我过去常表现得好像那是一种负担，但那实际上是最棒的。
It was wonderful. So now Stesha's asking me if I wouldn't mind if she brings her 20 beautiful friends over to my-- her beautiful French immersion friends. Which in Vernon, that's as exotic as it gets.
真是太棒了。所以现在斯特莎问我，如果她带她那20个漂亮的朋友来我家，我介不介意？她那些漂亮的法语沉浸式班的朋友。在弗农，那已经是最异国情调的了。
So they're gonna come over and put on their bathing suits and swim at my house? And I don't have to lift a finger? This was perfect to me. And this whole birthday would serve as a test at the end of the summer where I can prove to myself that I am cool, and I am ready to talk to girls.
所以她们要来我家换上泳衣游泳？我甚至连一根手指头都不用动？这对我是完美的。而整个生日派对将作为夏末的一次测试，我可以向自己证明我很酷，我已经准备好和女孩交谈了。
So it's the day of the party and all the pretty girls are showing up. And everything's going great. I'm playing them a burnt CD I just burnt on my new CD burner. It was all the coolest music I could think of. It was mostly just Blink-182.
派对当天，所有漂亮的女孩都出现了。一切都很顺利。我给她们放了一张我刚用新CD刻录机烧录的CD。那是我能想到的最酷的音乐。大部分只是Blink-182乐队的歌。
And we were all swimming in the lake and eating barbecue. And I was talking to the girls and catching up with Stesha. And I was doing my best to sit in a semi-reclined position with the sun hitting me at the right angle to accentuate my abdominal muscles.
我们都在湖里游泳和吃烧烤。我当时在和女孩们聊天，和斯特莎叙旧。我正在尽我所能以半躺的姿势坐着，让阳光以正确的角度照在我身上，以突显我的腹肌。
So it's a little bit later on, and all the girls are out on the dock and they're all laying in the sun. And two of them are at the end of the dock and they're hitting a volleyball back and forth and they hit the ball into the water.
过了一会儿，女孩们都在码头上，她们都躺在阳光下。其中两个在码头尽头，她们在来回打排球，球掉进了水里。
And they're all like, ugh, I don't want to go in the lake! I'm all warm and dry now! And I'm like, oh my God, this is my chance! Time to be a hero. So I stand up and I'm like, "I'll get that for you." And I dramatically take off my sunglasses.
她们都说，呃，我不想下湖！我全身都暖和又干爽了！我说，哦我的上帝，这就是我的机会！是时候成为英雄了。我站起来，说，“我帮你们去拿。”我戏剧性地摘下了太阳镜。
And my plan was not to merely just hop in the water and retrieve the ball. No, no, no. My plan was to run, to sprint as fast as I can and jump as far as I can. Because even at that age, I knew that that's what women really want is someone that can run and jump far.
我的计划不仅仅是跳进水里取回球。不，不，不。我的计划是奔跑，以最快的速度冲刺，尽可能跳得最远。因为即使在那样的年纪，我也知道女人真正想要的是一个能奔跑且跳得很远的人。
Right, girls? So I took off. And I'm running down the center of the dock and there's girls on both sides and everyone's watching me. And I might as well have had a cape on I felt like such a hero.
对吧，姑娘们？所以我跑了。我跑在码头的中心，女孩们在两边，每个人都在看着我。我觉得自己就像披着斗篷一样，感觉自己像个英雄。
I'm running down the dock, and with a few feet of dock left, trouble. Because we were swimming for a couple of hours, so the surface of the dock was really wet and slippery. And I slipped and I hit the deck, literally. But I had enough momentum from my heroic sprint that I was now sliding on the surface of the dock.
我顺着码头跑，还剩几英尺时，麻烦来了。因为我们游泳了几个小时，所以码头表面非常湿滑。我滑倒了，真的撞到了甲板上。但我刚才的英雄式冲刺带来的惯性使我开始在码头表面滑动。
Now had I just slid off the edge and into the water, it would've been totally fine. I would've been like, "Pshaw! That didn't even hurt. I'm gonna go and get the ball now."
如果我只是滑出边缘掉进水里，那完全没问题。我会说，“嘘！那一点也不疼。我现在去拿球。”
But that isn't what happened. Because there was a nail up. And the nail cut me. From here to about here. And about here, it caught on to my bathing suit.
但事情并非如此。因为有一根钉子露出来。那根钉子割伤了我。从这里到这里。然后在大约这个位置，它钩住了我的泳裤。
Now had the bathing suit ripped and then I fell in, it would've been OK. Or even if it fully caught my suit and it ejected me from the suit naked into the lake, I truly believe that I could've brought it back. That would've been OK.
如果泳裤撕裂然后我掉下去，那也没问题。甚至如果它完全钩住我的泳裤，把我赤身裸体地抛进湖里，我真心相信我能挽回局面。那也会没事的。
I would've been like, "Wow, what a freak accident! Could you pass me my trunks? I'm gonna go and get the ball now."
我会说，“哇，真是个奇怪的事故！能把泳裤递给我吗？我现在去拿球。”
But that isn't what happened. Because the good people at Quicksilver make too fine a product and my trunks didn't rip. So what happened was I went over the edge and I swung and I hit my head on the pillar. And my legs were straight up in the air kicking like mad. And I'm splashing around. My head is half underwater, and my penis is out.
但事情并非如此。因为Quicksilver的好人们制造了质量太好的产品，我的裤子没破。所以我翻过了边缘，我摆动了一下，头撞在了柱子上。我的双腿在空中疯狂地乱踢。我在水里乱拍。我的头有一半在水下，而我的阴茎露了出来。
So I'm upside down and I think I'm drowning and I don't know what's happening. I'm in fight or flight, I'm splashing. And what does one do when you're in what you perceive to be a life and death situation?
所以我倒挂着，以为自己快淹死了，不知道发生了什么。我在战斗或逃跑状态中，我在乱拍。当你处于你认为的生死攸关的情况时，你会怎么做？
"Mom! Mommy! Help Mom! Help Mom!"
“妈妈！妈咪！救救我妈！救救我妈！”
And what happened next I have to give to you second hand, because I was underwater. But legend has it that my mom was inside making a potato salad. And she heard me calling for help and she snapped into action and she knocked the screen sliding door off the track and she was hurdling over lawn furniture and weaving through girls. And she got to me and she pulled me to safety in a matter of seconds.
接下来发生的事我只能从别人口中转述，因为我当时在水下。但传说我妈妈当时在里面做土豆沙拉。她听到我呼救，立刻采取行动，把纱门从轨道上撞了下来，她跨过草坪家具，穿过人群。她在几秒钟内赶到我身边并把我拉到了安全地带。
And I was so confused. I was like, what, what the [BLEEP]? [BLEEP]. What the [BLEEP]? And I'll always remember, my mom whispered in my ear, "Honey, quit cursing."
我当时非常困惑。我当时在想，怎么，怎么回事？[哔]。什么鬼？我永远记得，我妈妈在我耳边低语，“亲爱的，别说脏话。”
And I'm covered in blood and I'm shaking. And I remember I turned my attention to the girls halfheartedly trying to conceal their laughter. And I looked out at the lake and I could see the ball. And it was long gone, it was floating away. Thank you.
我浑身是血，在颤抖。我记得我漫不经心地看向那些试图掩饰笑声的女孩们。我看向湖面，我能看到球。它早就没影了，漂走了。谢谢。
Sam Mullins. He's a comedian and comedy writer in Vancouver.
萨姆·马林斯。他是温哥华的一位喜剧演员和喜剧编剧。
[MUSIC - "POOL PARTY" BY THE TWO MAN GENTLEMAN BAND]
[音乐 - THE TWO MAN GENTLEMAN BAND的《泳池派对》]
Act Three, "The Beachcomber." OK, so the absolute beachiest radio show I think maybe that has ever been made-- I believe, anyway-- was done by my first boss at NPR, this documentary producer named Keith Talbot. He made this back in 1979. It was called Ocean Hour.
第三幕，“海滩拾荒者”。好的，我认为这大概是史上制作过的最具有海滩风情的广播节目了——总之我相信是这样——这是我刚进NPR时的老板，一位名叫基思·塔尔博特的纪录片制作人做的。他在1979年制作了这个节目。它叫《海洋时刻》。
And I love that show. Like I say, I think it's beachiest radio show mankind will ever produce, and here is one of my favorite parts.
我喜欢那个节目。就像我说的那样，我认为它是人类有史以来制作过的最具有海滩风情的广播节目，这是我最喜欢的部分之一。
Just before I play this, I should say this is such a piece of 1970s era public radio that there's no narration on the show giving the name of the interviewee who you're about to hear or where he is. That's how we rolled back then. Anyway, I hope you like this.
在播放之前，我应该说这是70年代公共广播的一个典型片段，节目中没有解说给出你即将听到的受访者的名字或他在哪里。那就是我们当时的风格。总之，我希望你喜欢这个。
Here is a scrounger's life. Everything is like a beachcomber.
这就是拾荒者的生活。一切都像个海滩拾荒者。
I have lived as poor as a man can live and still survive in United States of America in the 1970s. Because everything comes here somehow sooner or later.
我曾生活得像个在70年代的美国依然能生存的最穷的人。因为一切不知何故迟早都会来到这里。
Wood, oysters, the various other fish that you can get for the asking. Mullet, which is the big, good eating fish around here, along with trout and catfish, which come from the rivers. You have the river cat and the salt water cat. They seem to be cousins, but they taste a little different.
木头、牡蛎，以及你可以随手得到的各种其他鱼类。鲻鱼，这是这里最棒的食用鱼，还有鳟鱼和鲶鱼，它们来自河流。你有河鲶和海鲶。它们似乎是表亲，但味道有点不同。
And in addition to all of that, you get the kinds of things that the sea brings, which is from boats. There's always a certain amount of movement of cargo in boats as well as fish.
除了所有这些，你还能得到大海带来的东西，来自船只。船上的货物和鱼类总是有一定的流动。
And firewood around here is for the asking. In a city like New York or Washington, firewood I'm sure costs $100 a truckload, $200. Round here you can go out and fill it up for nothing.
这里的木柴随手可得。在纽约或华盛顿这样的城市，木柴肯定要100美元一卡车，200美元。在这里你可以免费装满它。
There is a theory, for example, in archaeology that all of the early settlements were on the coast of man. That that's where the easiest life has always been, where everything was for the taking and you had the sea and you had the land together and the various mutations between them.
例如，考古学中有一种理论认为，所有早期定居点都在人类的海岸线上。那一直是最简单的生活方式，你可以随意获取一切，你拥有海洋和陆地，以及它们之间的各种变异。
And that's where food chains likely start, where you have that melting land or that solidifying water. That's where the organisms get their start, especially if you have the right climate.
那很可能是食物链开始的地方，在那里你拥有融化的陆地或固化的水。那就是生物开始的地方，特别是如果你有合适的气候。
As a poor man, it means that things are coming to me which don't happen very much on the prairie or in the big cities. Nothing comes to your door in a big city except a cop or a taxi driver or something. But here things will actually come to your door.
作为一个穷人，这意味着东西会来到我面前，而在大草原或大城市里这种情况不会经常发生。在大城市里，除了警察、出租车司机或类似的人，没有什么东西会来到你的门口。但在这里，东西真的会来到你的门口。
I have a houseful of found objects, and they get more beautiful all the time. And every day I pick up something. All kind of shells and driftwood, trees. There's an enormous number of things that nature presents to you.
我有一屋子的发现物，而且它们变得越来越美。每天我都会捡到东西。各种贝壳和浮木、树木。大自然呈现给你的东西极其丰富。
This coast gives a way of life that is really almost-- this is like a myth to me. If you can imagine living like the 19th century, 18th century. Thoreau could've lived here. Thoreau could still live here. And yet most people in America think that that has gone.
这个海岸提供了一种生活方式，这对我来说简直就像个神话。如果你能想象生活在19世纪、18世纪。梭罗本可以住在这里。梭罗仍然可以住在这里。然而大多数美国人认为那种生活已经消失了。
And yet we're in a time warp here. Temporarily, because as you see, it's going. It's going hourly right now.
然而我们在这里处于一个时间扭曲中。暂时是这样，因为如你所见，它正在消失。现在每小时都在消失。
[OCEAN WAVES]
[海浪声]
An excerpt from Ocean Hour in 1979. A link to that entire program is at our website, ThisAmericanLife.org.
这是1979年《海洋时刻》的节选。完整节目的链接在我们网站ThisAmericanLife.org上。
Coming up, David Sedaris and his family go to the beach. Except for one of them. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，大卫·塞达里斯和他的家人去海滩。除了其中一个。一分钟后，从芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today after these awful weeks where we have all had to learn the phrase "polar vortex" to describe daily life in the United States, we have decided that we're going to spend an hour getting away from all that with stories of places where it is hot, with stories from the beach.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天，在经历了这些可怕的几周，我们都不得不学习“极地漩涡”这个词来描述美国日常生活之后，我们决定花一个小时远离这一切，去听听关于那些炎热地方的故事，听听来自海滩的故事。
We've arrived at Act Four of our show. Act Four, "Now We Are Five."
我们来到了节目的第四幕。第四幕，“现在我们是五个人”。
OK, if you're a beach family, you go to the beach every year, even bad years for your family. That is just what you do.
好的，如果你是一个海滩家庭，你每年都会去海滩，即使对你的家庭来说是不幸的年份。这就是你们会做的事情。
David Sedaris has a story about that happening in his family. The story was recently published in The New Yorker . I'm guessing that some of you may have read it. Here at our show, we really loved this story and know lots of you have not seen it, so here it is. Here's David Sedaris.
大卫·塞达里斯有一个关于他家里发生这种情况的故事。这个故事最近发表在《纽约客》上。我猜你们中的一些人可能读过。在我们的节目里，我们非常喜欢这个故事，并且知道你们中的许多人还没看过，所以这就是它。这就是大卫·塞达里斯。
In late May of last year, a few weeks shy of her 50th birthday, my youngest sister Tiffany committed suicide. She was living in a room in a beat-up house on the hard side of Somerville, Massachusetts, and had been dead, the coroner guessed, for at least five days before her door was battered down.
去年5月底，离我最小的妹妹蒂芙尼50岁生日还有几周时，她自杀身亡了。她住在马萨诸塞州萨默维尔市艰难地带一栋破旧房子的房间里，法医猜测她已经去世至少五天了，直到她的门被撞开。
I was given the news over a white courtesy phone while at the Dallas airport. Then, because my plane to Baton Rouge was boarding and I wasn't sure what else to do, I got on it. The following morning, I boarded another plane, this one to Atlanta. And the day after that, I flew to Nashville, thinking all the while about my ever shrinking family.
我在达拉斯机场用一台免费电话得到了这个消息。然后，因为我飞往巴吞鲁日的飞机正在登机，我不知道该做什么，就登上了飞机。第二天早上，我又登上了另一架飞往亚特兰大的飞机。在那之后的一天，我飞往纳什维尔，一直在思考我那不断缩小的家庭。
A person expects his parents to die. But a sibling? I felt I'd lost the identity I'd enjoyed since 1968, when my brother was born. "Six kids?" people would say. "How do your poor folks manage?"
一个人会预料到父母会去世。但兄弟姐妹呢？我觉得我失去了自1968年我弟弟出生以来我所享受的身份。“六个孩子？”人们会说。“你们贫穷的父母是怎么管理的？”
There were a lot of big families in the neighborhood I grew up in. Every other house was a fiefdom, so I never gave it much thought until I became an adult and my friends started having children. One or two seemed reasonable, but anything beyond that struck me as outrageous.
我长大的邻里有很多大家庭。每隔一户人家就是一个封地，所以我从未太在意，直到我成年，朋友们开始有了孩子。一两个似乎很合理，但超过这个数字让我觉得不可思议。
A couple Hugh and I knew in Normandy would occasionally come together with their wrecking crew of three. When they'd leave several hours later, every last part of me would feel violated. Take those kids, double them, and subtract the cable TV. That's what my parents had to deal with.
我和休在诺曼底认识的一对夫妇偶尔会带着他们那三个破坏狂孩子一起出现。当他们几个小时后离开时，我身体的每一个部分都感到被侵犯。把那些孩子翻倍，再减去有线电视。这就是我父母必须面对的。
Now though, there weren't six. Only five. "And you can't really say there used to be six," I told my sister Lisa. "It just makes people uncomfortable."
不过现在，已经没有六个了。只有五个。“而且你不能真的说曾经有六个，”我告诉我的妹妹丽莎。“这只会让人感到不舒服。”
I recalled a father and son I'd met in California a few years back. "So are there other children?" I asked. "There are," the man said. "Three who are living, and a daughter-- Chloe-- who died before she was born 18 years ago."
我想起了几年前我在加州遇到的一对父子。“那么还有其他孩子吗？”我问。“有，”那个人说。“三个活着的，还有一个女儿——克洛伊——在18年前出生前就去世了。”
That's not fair, I remember thinking. Because, I mean, what's a person supposed to do with that?
那不公平，我记得当时心想。因为，我的意思是，一个人该拿那个怎么办？
Compared to most 49 year-olds, or even most 49 month-olds, Tiffany didn't have much. She did leave a will though. In it she decreed that we, her family, could not have her body or attend her memorial service. "So put that in your pipe and smoke it!" our mother would've said.
与大多数49岁的人，甚至大多数49个月大的人相比，蒂芙尼没有多少东西。但她确实留下了遗嘱。在遗嘱中，她规定我们，她的家人，不能拥有她的尸体或参加她的追悼会。“那么把你这套留着自己抽吧！”我母亲会说。
A few days after getting the news, my sister Amy drove to Somerville with a friend and collected two boxes of things from Tiffany's room. Family photos-- many of which had been ripped into pieces-- comment cards from a neighborhood grocery store, notebooks, receipts. The bed, a mattress on the floor, had been taken away and a large industrial fan had been set up.
在得到消息几天后，我妹妹艾米带着一个朋友开车去了萨默维尔，从蒂芙尼的房间里收集了两箱东西。家庭照片——许多已经被撕成了碎片——社区杂货店的评论卡、笔记本、收据。那张在地板上的床垫已经被拿走了，并安装了一台巨大的工业风扇。
Amy snapped some pictures while she was there. And individually and in groups, those of us left studied them for clues.
艾米在那里拍了一些照片。我们剩下的人单独或成群结队地研究它们寻找线索。
A paper plate on a dresser that had several drawers missing. A phone number written on a wall. A collection of mop handles, each one a different color, arranged like cattails in a barrel painted green.
梳妆台上一个少了几个抽屉的纸盘子。墙上写着一个电话号码。一堆拖把柄，每一个颜色都不同，像桶里的香蒲一样排列着，漆成了绿色。
Six months before our sister killed herself, I'd made plans for us all to gather at a beach house on Emerald Isle, off the coast of North Carolina. My family used to vacation there every summer, but after my mother died we stopped going. Not because we lost interest, but because it was she who always made the arrangements and more importantly, paid for it.
在我们妹妹自杀六个月前，我已经计划我们全家人聚集在北卡罗来纳州海岸外的翡翠岛的一栋海滩别墅里。我家人过去每年夏天都在那里度假，但母亲去世后我们就没再去了。不是因为我们失去了兴趣，而是因为总是她负责安排，更重要的是，支付费用。
The place I found, with the help of my sister-in-law Kathy, had six bedrooms and a small swimming pool. Our week long rental period began on Saturday, June 8th, and we arrived to find a delivery woman standing in the driveway with seven pounds of seafood, a sympathy gift sent by friends. "They's slaw in there too," she said, handing over the bags.
在我嫂子凯茜的帮助下，我找到的那个地方有六间卧室和一个小游泳池。我们为期一周的租赁期从6月8日星期六开始，我们到达时发现一位送货员站在车道上，带着七磅海鲜，这是朋友们送来的慰问礼物。“里面还有凉拌卷心菜，”她说，递过袋子。
In the past, when my family rented a cottage, my sisters and I would crowd the door like puppies around a food dish. Our father would unlock it and we'd tear through the house claiming rooms.
过去，当我家人租小屋时，我的姐妹们和我会像食物盘周围的小狗一样挤在门口。我父亲会打开门，我们会冲进房子抢房间。
I always picked the biggest one facing the ocean. And just as I'd start to unpack, my parents would enter and tell me that this was theirs. "I mean, just who the hell do you think you are?" my father would ask. He and my mother would move in and I would get booted to what was called the maid's room. It was always on the ground level, a kind of dank shed next to where the car was parked.
我总是挑选最大的一间面向大海的。正当我开始拆包时，父母会进来告诉我那是他们的。“我的意思是，你以为你自己是谁？”我父亲会问。他和母亲会搬进去，而我会被踢到所谓的佣人房。它总是在底层，一种停放汽车旁边的潮湿棚屋。
There was never an interior stairway leading to the upper floor. Instead I had to take the outside steps, and more often than not, knock on the locked front door like a beggar hoping to be invited in.
从来没有通往楼上的内部楼梯。相反，我必须走外面的台阶，而且通常情况下，像个乞丐一样敲锁住的前门，希望能被邀请进去。
"What do you want?" my sisters would ask. "I want to come inside."
“你想要什么？”我的姐妹们会问。“我想进来。”
"That's funny," Lisa, the eldest, would say to the others who were gathered like disciples around her. "Did you hear something, a whining sound? What is it that makes a noise like that? A hermit crab? A little sea slug?"
“那很有趣，”丽莎，最年长的，会对比她周围像门徒一样聚集的人说。“你们听到了吗，一种呜呜声？是什么东西发出了那样的声音？寄居蟹？小海蛞蝓？”
Normally there was a social divide between the three oldest and three youngest children in my family. Lisa, Gretchen, and I treated the others like servants and did very well for ourselves. At the beach though, all bets were off. And it was just upstairs against downstairs, meaning everyone against me.
通常我家里最大的三个孩子和最小的三个孩子之间有社会鸿沟。丽莎、格雷琴和我把其他人当作仆人，我们自己做得很好。但在海滩上，一切都不好说了。那就是楼上对抗楼下，意味着每个人都对抗我。
This time, because I was paying, I got to choose the best room. Amy moved in next door, and my brother Paul, his wife, and their 10-year-old daughter Maddie took the spot next to her. That was it for oceanfront. The others arrived later and had to take the leftovers.
这次，因为是我付钱，我得以选择最好的房间。艾米搬到隔壁，我弟弟保罗、他的妻子和他们10岁的女儿麦迪搬进了旁边的位置。海滨就这些了。其他人后来才到，不得不捡剩下的。
Lisa's room faced the street, as did my father's. Gretchen's faced the street and was intended for someone who was paralyzed. Hanging from the ceiling were electric pulleys designed to lift a harnessed body into and out of bed.
丽莎的房间面向街道，我父亲的也是。格雷琴的面向街道，是为瘫痪的人准备的。天花板上悬挂着电动滑轮，旨在将身体系上安全带抬进或抬出床。
Unlike the cottages of our youth, this one did not have a maid's room. It was too new and fancy for that, as were the homes that surrounded it.
与我们年轻时的小屋不同，这栋房子没有佣人房。它对那种设施来说太新太豪华了，周围的房子也一样。
Traditionally, all the island houses were on stilts. But more and more often now, the ground floors are filled in. They all have beachy names and are painted beachy colors. But most of those built after Hurricane Fran hit the coast in 1996 are three stories tall and look almost suburban.
传统上，岛上的房子都在高跷上。但现在越来越多的底层被填满了。它们都有海滩的名字，涂着海滩的颜色。但大多数在1996年弗兰飓风袭击海岸后建造的房子都有三层楼高，看起来几乎像郊区住宅。
This place was vast and airy. The kitchen table sat 12. And there was not one, but two dishwashers.
这个地方广阔而通风。餐桌能坐下12个人。而且不只一个，而是两个洗碗机。
All the pictures were ocean related. Seascapes and lighthouses, all with the airborne Vs that are shorthand for seagull. A sampler on the living room wall read "Old shellers never die, they simply conch out."
所有的画都与海洋有关。海景和灯塔，全都有象征海鸥的空中的V字。客厅墙上的一块采样画写着“老贝壳收藏者永远不会死，他们只是没法再捡了。”
On the round clock beside it, the numbers lay in an indecipherable heap, as if they'd come unglued. Just above them were printed the words "Who cares?" This was what we found ourselves saying whenever anyone asked the time. "Who cares?"
旁边圆钟上的数字乱作一团，好像脱胶了一样。就在它们上方印刷着“谁在乎？”这正是我们发现自己无论何时有人问时间时都会说的话。“谁在乎？”
The day before we arrived at the beach, Tiffany's obituary ran in the Raleigh News & Observer. It was submitted by Gretchen, who stated that our sister had passed away peacefully at her home. This made it sound as if she were very old and had a house. But what else could you do?
我们到达海滩的前一天，蒂芙尼的讣告刊登在《罗利新闻与观察家报》上。是由格雷琴提交的，她声明我们妹妹在家里平静地去世了。这听起来好像她很老而且有房子。但还能做什么呢？
People were leaving responses on the paper's website, and one fellow wrote that Tiffany used to come into the video store where he worked in Somerville. When his glasses broke, she offered him a pair she had found while foraging for art supplies in somebody's trashcan. He said she also gave him a Playboy magazine from the 1960s that included a photo spread titled "The Ass Menagerie."
人们在报纸网站上留下回复，一个人写道，蒂芙尼过去常去他在萨默维尔工作的视频店。当他的眼镜碎了时，她给了他一副她从某人的垃圾桶里寻找艺术品时发现的眼镜。他说她还给了他一本1960年代的《花花公子》杂志，其中包括名为“驴子动物园”的照片专栏。
This was fascinating, as we didn't really know our sister very well. Each of us had pulled away from the family at some point in our lives. We'd had to, in order to forge our own identities, to go from being a Sedaris to our own specific Sedaris.
这很有趣，因为我们并不真正了解我们的妹妹。我们每个人都在生命的某个时刻远离过家庭。我们不得不这样做，为了打造我们自己的身份，从一个塞达里斯变成我们自己特定的塞达里斯。
Tiffany though, stayed away. She might promise to come home for Christmas, but at the last minute there'd always be some excuse. She missed her plane, she had to work. The same would happen with our summer vacations.
但蒂芙尼一直远离。她可能会承诺回家过圣诞节，但最后一刻总会有各种借口。她错过了飞机，她必须工作。我们的暑假也会发生同样的事情。
"The rest of us managed to make it," I'd say, aware of how old and guilt trippy I sounded. All of us would be disappointed by her absence, though for different reasons.
“我们其他人都能做到，”我会说，意识到我听起来有多老和多么利用负罪感。我们所有人都会因为她的缺席而失望，尽管原因各不相同。
Even if you weren't getting along with Tiffany at the time, you couldn't deny the show she put on. The dramatic entrances, the nonstop professional grade insults, the chaos she'd inevitably leave in her wake. One day she'd throw a dish at you and the next she'd create a mosaic made of the shards. When allegiances with one brother or sister flamed out, she'd take up with someone else.
即使你当时和蒂芙尼相处得不好，你也无法否认她展示出的表演。戏剧性的入场，不停歇的专业级侮辱，她不可避免地会在身后留下的混乱。今天她会朝你扔盘子，明天她会用碎片制作马赛克。当与一个兄弟姐妹的联盟破裂时，她会和另一个人在一起。
At no time did she get along with everybody, but there was always someone she was in contact with. Toward the end, it was Lisa. But before that, we'd all had our turn. The last time she joined us on Emerald Isle was 1986. "And even then, she left after three days," Gretchen reminded us.
她从未在任何时候与每个人都相处得好，但总有某个人是她保持联系的。快到最后时，是丽莎。但在那之前，我们都轮到过。她最后一次在翡翠岛加入我们是1986年。“即便那时，她三天后就离开了，”格雷琴提醒我们。
As kids, we spent our beach time swimming. Then we became teenagers and devoted ourselves to tanning.
作为孩子，我们花在海滩上的时间就是游泳。然后我们成了青少年，致力于晒黑。
There's a certain kind of talk that takes place when you're lying dazed in the sun, and I've always been partial to it. On the first afternoon of our most recent trip, we laid out one of the bedspreads we'd had as children and arranged ourselves side by side on it, trading stories about Tiffany.
当你神志不清地躺在阳光下时，会发生某种交谈，我一直很喜欢这种交谈。在我们最近一次旅行的第一个下午，我们铺开了一条我们小时候用过的床罩，并排躺在上面，交换关于蒂芙尼的故事。
"What about the Halloween she spent on that Army base? And the time she showed up at Dad's birthday party with a black eye."
“那年万圣节她在军队基地度过记得吗？还有她带着黑眼圈出现在爸爸生日派对上的时候。”
"I remember this girl she met years ago at a party," I began when my turn came. "She'd been talking about facial scars and how terrible it would be to have one. So Tiffany said, 'I have a little scar on my face and I don't think it's so awful.' 'Well,' the girl said, 'you would if you were pretty.'"
“我记得这个女孩，她几年前在派对上认识的，”轮到我时我开始说。“她在谈论面部疤痕以及脸上有一道疤痕有多可怕。所以蒂芙尼说，‘我脸上有一道小疤痕，我不觉得有什么可怕的。’‘嗯，’那个女孩说，‘如果你长得漂亮，你就会这么觉得了。’”
Amy laughed and rolled over onto her stomach. "Oh, that's a good line."
艾米笑了，翻身趴着。“哦，那是一句好台词。”
I rearranged the towel I was using as a pillow. "Idn't it, though?"
我重新调整了用作枕头的毛巾。“难道不是吗？”
Coming from someone else, the story might have been upsetting. But not being pretty was never one of Tiffany's problems, especially when she was in her 20s and 30s and men tumbled helpless before her. "Funny," I said, "but I don't remember a scar on her face."
如果来自别人，这个故事可能会令人不安。但不够漂亮从来不是蒂芙尼的问题，尤其是当她在20多岁和30多岁时，男人们在她面前无助地摔倒。“有趣的是，”我说，“但我记不起她脸上有疤痕。”
I stayed in the sun too long that day and got a burn on my forehead. That was basically it for me and the beach blanket. I made brief appearances for the rest of the week, stopping to dry off after a swim. But mainly I spent my days on a bike, cycling up and down the coast and thinking about what had happened.
那天我在阳光下待得太久，前额被晒伤了。对于我和海滩毯来说，基本上就这样了。这一周剩下的时间里我只短暂地出现，游泳后停下来擦干。但主要是白天骑自行车，沿着海岸骑行，思考发生了什么。
While the rest of us seemed to get along effortlessly, with Tiffany it always felt like work. She and I usually made up after arguing, but our last fight took it out of me. And at the time of her death, we hadn't spoken in eight years.
虽然我们其他人似乎不费吹灰之力就相处得很好，但对于蒂芙尼，总是感觉像是工作。她和我在争吵后通常会和好，但我们的最后一次争吵让我耗尽了精力。在她去世时，我们已经八年没说话了。
During that period, I regularly found myself near Somerville. And though I'd always toy with the idea of contacting her, I never did, despite my father's encouragement. Meanwhile, I'd get reports from him and Lisa. Tiffany had lost her apartment, had gone on disability, had moved into a room found for her by a social service agency.
在那期间，我经常发现自己在萨默维尔附近。尽管我总是考虑联系她，但我从没这样做，尽管我父亲鼓励我。同时，我会从他和丽莎那里得到报告。蒂芙尼失去了公寓，靠残疾金生活，搬进了一个社会服务机构为她找到的房间。
Perhaps she was more forthcoming with her friends, but her family got things only in bits and pieces. She didn't talk with us so much as at us. Great blocks of speech that were in turns funny, astute, and so contradictory it was hard to connect the sentence you were hearing to the one that preceded it. Before we stopped speaking, I could always tell when she was on the phone. I'd walk into the house and hear Hugh say, "Uh huh, uh huh, uh huh."
也许她和朋友们更坦率，但她的家人只得到了零星的碎片。她不是和我们说话，而是对我们大喊。一大段一大段的谈话，有时很有趣、精明，而且自相矛盾到很难把你听到的句子和你刚才听到的那句联系起来。在我们停止交谈之前，我总能知道她在打电话。我会走进屋子听休说，“嗯哼，嗯哼，嗯哼。”
In addition to the two boxes that Amy had filled in Somerville, she also brought down our sister's 1978 ninth grade yearbook. Among the messages inscribed by her classmates was the following, written by someone who had drawn a marijuana leaf beside her name.
除了艾米在萨默维尔装满的那两箱东西外，她还带下了我们妹妹1978年九年级的年鉴。在同学们书写的留言中，有下面这一条，是由一个在她名字旁边画了大麻叶的人写的。
"Tiffany, you are a one of a kind girl, so stay that way, you unique ass. I'm only sorry we couldn't have partied more together. This school sucks to hell. Stay cool, stoned, drunk, [BLEEP] up. Check your ass later."
“蒂芙尼，你是一个独一无二的女孩，所以保持那样，你这个独特的混蛋。我只遗憾我们没能多一起聚聚。这学校烂透了。保持酷，嗑药，喝醉，[哔] 搞砸了。回头再来找你。”
Then there's, "Tiffany, I'm looking forward to getting high with you this summer." And "Tiffany, call me some time this summer and we'll go out and get blitzed."
然后还有，“蒂芙尼，我很期待这个夏天和你一起嗨。”以及“蒂芙尼，这个夏天什么时候给我打电话，我们一起出去喝个酩酊大醉。”
A few weeks after these messages were written, Tiffany ran away and was subsequently sent to a disciplinary institution in Maine called Elan. According to what she told us later, it was a horrible place. She returned home in 1980, having spent two years there. And from that point on, none of us can recall a conversation in which she did not mention it.
在这些留言写下几周后，蒂芙尼逃跑了，随后被送到缅因州一个名为Elan的纪律机构。据她后来告诉我们的，那是一个可怕的地方。她在1980年回到家，在那里待了两年。从那时起，我们没人能回忆起她没有提到过那个地方的谈话。
She blamed the family for sending her off. But we, her siblings, had nothing to do with it. Paul for instance. Paul was 10 when she left. I was 21.
她责怪家人把她送走。但我们，她的兄弟姐妹，与此无关。比如保罗。她离开时保罗才10岁。我21岁。
For a year I sent her monthly letters. Then she wrote and told me to stop.
一年里我每月给她写信。然后她写信让我停止。
As for my parents, there were only so many times they could apologize. "We had other kids," they said in their defense. "You think we could let the world stop on account of any one of you?"
至于我的父母，他们道歉的次数太多了。“我们还有其他孩子，”他们辩护说。“你以为为了你们中的任何一个，我们能让世界停下来吗？”
We were at the beach  for three days before Lisa and our father-- who is now 90-- joined us. Being on the island meant missing the spinning classes he takes in Raleigh, so I found a fitness center not far from the rental cottage and every afternoon he and I would spend some time there. On the way over, we'd talk to each other. But as soon as we mounted our stationary bikes, we'd each retreat into our own thoughts.
我们在海滩待了三天后，丽莎和我们现在90岁的父亲才加入我们。在岛上意味着错过他在罗利参加的动感单车课，所以我找到了离租赁小屋不远的一个健身中心，每天下午他和我会花点时间在那里。去的那路上，我们会交谈。但一旦我们骑上固定自行车，我们就会各自退回到自己的思绪中。
It was a small place, not very lively. A mute television oversaw the room, tuned to the Weather Channel and reminding us that there's always a catastrophe somewhere or other, always someone flooded from his home, or running for his life from a funnel shaped cloud.
那是个小地方，不太热闹。一台静音电视机监视着房间，调到了天气频道，提醒我们某个地方总有灾难，总有人被洪水淹没了家园，或从漏斗状云层下逃命。
Toward the end of the week, I came upon my father in Amy's room, sifting through the photos that Tiffany had destroyed. In his hand was a fragment of my mother's head with a patch of blue sky behind her. Under what circumstances had this been ripped up, I wondered. It seemed such a melodramatic gesture, like throwing a glass against a wall. Something someone in a movie would do.
一周快结束时，我在艾米的房间里遇到了我父亲，他在翻看蒂芙尼毁掉的照片。他手里拿着我母亲头部的一个碎片，背后是一片蓝天。我不禁想，在什么情况下这被撕碎了？这似乎是一种戏剧性的姿态，就像把玻璃杯扔在墙上。电影里的人会做的事情。
"Just awful," my father whispered. "A person's life reduced to one lousy box."
“真是太糟糕了，”我父亲低声说。“一个人的生活被缩减成一个烂箱子。”
I put my hand on his shoulder. [CLEARS  THROAT] "Actually, there are two of them."
我把手放在他的肩膀上。[清嗓子] “实际上，有两个。”
He corrected himself. "Two lousy boxes."
他纠正了自己。“两个烂箱子。”
One afternoon on Emerald Isle, we all rode to the Food Lion for groceries. I was in the produce department looking at red onions when my brother sneaked up from behind and let loose with a load "Achoo!" This while whipping a bouquet of wet parsley through the air.
翡翠岛的一个下午，我们全家骑车去Food Lion超市买杂货。我在农产品部门看红洋葱时，我弟弟从背后溜过来，大声打了一个“阿嚏！”同时把一束湿欧芹甩向空中。
I felt the spray on the back of my neck and froze, thinking a very sick stranger had just sneezed on me. It's a neat trick, but he also dowsed the Indian woman who was standing to my left. She was wearing a blood-colored sari, so got it on her bare arm as well as her neck and the lower part of her back.
我感觉到脖子后面有喷雾，僵住了，以为一个非常生病的陌生人刚打喷嚏在我身上。这是一个巧妙的把戏，但他还把站在我左边的印度女人泼湿了。她穿着血色的纱丽，所以她的裸露手臂以及脖子和背部下半部分都沾上了。
"Sorry, man!" Paul said when she turned around, horrified. "I was just playing a joke on my brother!"
“抱歉，伙计！”那个女人惊恐地转过身时，保罗说。“我只是在跟我哥哥开个玩笑！”
The woman had many thin bracelets on and they jangled as she brushed her hand against the back of her head. "You called her man," I said to him after she walked off.
那个女人戴着许多细手镯，当她把手扫过头后时，手镯发出叮当声。“你叫她伙计，”在她走开后我对他说道。
"For real?" he asked. Amy mimicked him perfectly. "For real?"
“真的吗？”他问。艾米完美地模仿了他。“真的吗？”
Over the phone, my brother, like me, is often mistaken for a woman. As we continued shopping, he told us that his van had recently broken down. And that when he called for a tow truck, the dispatcher said, "We'll be right out, sweetie!"
在电话里，我弟弟像我一样，经常被误认为女人。当我们继续购物时，他告诉我们他的货车最近抛锚了。当他叫拖车时，调度员说，“我们马上就到，甜心！”
He lowered a watermelon into the cart and turned to his daughter. "Maddie's got a daddy who talks like a lady, but she don't care, do she?" Giggling, she punched him in the stomach, and I was struck by how comfortable the two of them are with each other. Our father was a figure of authority, but Paul is more of a playmate.
他把一个西瓜放进购物车，转向他的女儿。“麦迪有一个说话像女士的爸爸，但她不在乎，对吧？”咯咯笑着，她打了他肚子一下，我被他们俩相处得多么自在所打动。我们的父亲是权威形象，但保罗更像个玩伴。
When we went to the beach as children, on or about the fourth day, our father would say, "Wouldn't it be nice to buy a cottage down here?" We'd get our hopes up and then he would bring practical concerns into it.
当我们小时候去海滩时，在第四天左右，我父亲会说，“在这里买个小屋不是很好吗？”我们会充满希望，然后他会提出实际的顾虑。
They weren't petty. Buying a house that will eventually get blown away by a hurricane probably isn't the best way to spend your money. But still, we wanted one desperately.
它们并不琐碎。购买一栋最终会被飓风吹走的房子可能不是花钱的最佳方式。但我们仍然非常渴望要一个。
I told myself when I was young that one day I would buy a beach house and then it would be everyone's. As long as they followed my draconian rules and never stopped thanking me for it.
我年轻时告诉自己，有一天我会买一栋海滩别墅，然后它会成为每个人的。只要他们遵守我严苛的规则，并且永远不要停止因为这个而感谢我。
Thus it was on Wednesday morning midway through our vacation Hugh and I contacted a real estate agent named Phyllis, who took us around to look at available properties. On Friday afternoon, we made an offer on an oceanfront cottage not far from the one we were renting. And before sunset, our bid was accepted.
于是，在我们假期中间的星期三上午，休和我联系了一位名叫菲莉丝的房地产经纪人，她带我们去看可用的房产。星期五下午，我们对离我们租的小屋不远的一栋海滨小屋出价了。日落之前，我们的报价被接受了。
I made the announcement at the dinner table and got the reaction I had expected. "Now wait a minute," my father said. "You need to think clearly here!"
我在餐桌上宣布了这个消息，并得到了我预期的反应。“现在等一下，”我父亲说。“你需要清楚地考虑一下！”
"I already have," I told him. "OK then, how old is the roof? How many times has it been replaced in the past 10 years?"
“我已经考虑清楚了，”我告诉他。“那么，屋顶有多大年纪了？过去10年换过几次？”
"When can we move in?" Gretchen asked. Lisa wanted to know if she could bring her dogs, and Amy asked what the house was named.
“我们可以什么时候搬进去？”格雷琴问。丽莎想知道她能不能带她的狗，艾米问房子叫什么名字。
"Right now, it's called Fantastic Place," I told her. "But we're going to change it."
“现在它叫梦幻之地，”我告诉她。“但我们要改名字。”
I used to think the ideal name for a beach house was the Ship Shape. Now though, I had a better idea. "We're going to call it The Sea Section."
我过去认为海滩别墅的理想名字是“船形”。但现在我有了一个更好的主意。“我们要把它叫作‘海区’。”
My father put down his hamburger. "Oh no you're not!"
我父亲放下了汉堡。“噢不，你不能！”
"But it's perfect!" I argued. "The name's supposed to be beachy, and if it's a pun, all the better." I brought up a cottage we'd seen earlier in the day called Dune Our Thing, and my father winced.
“但它很完美！”我争辩道。“名字应该是海滩风格的，如果是双关语，那就更好了。”我提到了我们当天早些时候看到的一栋名为“筑我们的事”的小屋，我父亲畏缩了一下。
"What about naming it Tiffany?" he said. Our silence translated to let's pretend we didn't hear that. He picked his hamburger back up. "I think it's a great idea. The perfect way to pay our respects."
“把它命名为蒂芙尼怎么样？”他说。我们的沉默翻译过来就是让我们假装没听到。他重新拿起汉堡。“我觉得这是个好主意。表达我们敬意的完美方式。”
"If that's the case, we could name it after Mom," I told him. "Or half after Mom and half after Tiffany. But it's a house, not a tombstone, and it wouldn't fit in with the names of the other houses."
“如果是那样的话，我们可以用妈妈的名字命名，”我告诉他。“或者一半以妈妈命名，一半以蒂芙尼命名。但这是一栋房子，不是墓碑，而且它不符合其他房子的名字。”
"Oh baloney!" my father said. "Fitting in! That's not who we are. That's not what we're about."
“噢胡说！”我父亲说。“合群！那不是我们是谁。那不是我们要谈论的。”
Paul interrupted to nominate the Conch Sucker. Amy's suggestion had the word seamen in it, and Gretchen's was even dirtier.
保罗打断说要提名“海螺吸吮者”。艾米的建议里有“海员”这个词，而格雷琴的甚至更脏。
"What's wrong with the name it already has?" Lisa asked. "No, no, no," my father said, forgetting I think, that this wasn't his decision.
“它原来的名字有什么不好？”丽莎问。“不，不，不，”我父亲说，我想他是忘了这根本不是他决定的。
A few days later, after the buyer's remorse had kicked in, I'd wonder if I hadn't bought the house as a way of saying, see, it's just that easy. No hemming and hawing, no asking to look at the septic tank. Rather you make your family happy and iron out the details later.
几天后，买家后悔的感觉涌上心头，我怀疑我是不是买这栋房子是为了以此说，看，这很容易。没有犹豫不决，没有要求看化粪池。反而是你让你的家人快乐，然后再处理细节。
The cottage we bought is two stories tall and was built in 1978. It's on proper stilts and has two rear decks, one above the other overlooking the ocean. It was rented to vacationers until late September, but Phyllis allowed us to drop by and show it to the family the following morning after we'd checked out of the house we'd been staying in.
我们买下的小屋有两层，建于1978年。它在高跷上，有两个后甲板，一个在另一个上面，俯瞰着海洋。它租给度假者直到9月底，但菲莉丝允许我们顺便过来，在我们退房后的第二天早上向家人展示。
A place always looks different-- worse, most often-- after you've made the commitment to buy it. So while the others raced up and down the stairs claiming their future bedrooms, I held my nose to a vent and caught a whiff of mildew.
一栋房子总是看起来不同——通常更糟——在你承诺买下它之后。所以当其他人在楼上楼下跑着争夺他们未来的卧室时，我把鼻子凑近通风口，闻到了一股霉味。
The sale included the furniture, so I also made an inventory of the Barcaloungers and massive TVs I would eventually be getting rid of, along with the shell patterned bedspreads and cushions with anchors on them. "For our beach house, I want to have a train theme," I announced. "Trains on the curtains, trains on the towels. We're gonna go all out." "Oh brother," my father moaned.
出售包括家具，所以我也列了一份清单，清单上有我最终要处理掉的巴卡躺椅和巨大的电视，还有贝壳图案的床罩和有锚图案的靠垫。“对于我们的海滩别墅，我想有一个火车主题，”我宣布。“窗帘上有火车，毛巾上有火车。我们要全力以赴。” “噢哥哥，”我父亲哀叹道。
We sketched a plan to return for Thanksgiving. And after saying goodbye to one another, my family splintered into groups and headed off to our respective homes. There'd been a breeze at the beach house, but once we left the island the air grew still. As the heat intensified, so did the general feeling of depression.
我们制定了感恩节回来的计划。道别之后，我的家人分成小组前往各自的家。海滩别墅那边有微风，但一旦离开岛屿，空气就变得静止了。随着热度加剧，抑郁的感觉也随之加剧。
Throughout the '60s and '70s, the road back to Raleigh took us past Smithfield and a billboard on the outskirts of town that read "Welcome to Klan Country." This time we took a different route, one my brother recommend.
在整个60年代和70年代，回罗利的路经过史密斯菲尔德，镇郊的一块广告牌上写着“欢迎来到三K党国家”。这次我们走了一条不同的路线，我弟弟推荐的那条。
Hugh drove and my father sat beside him. I slumped down in the back seat next to Amy and every time I raised my head, I'd see the same soybean field or low slung cinder block building we'd seemingly passed 20 minutes earlier.
休开车，我父亲坐在他旁边。我瘫倒在艾米旁边的后座上，每次我抬起头，我看到的似乎都是我们20分钟前刚经过的同一块大豆田或低矮的煤渣块建筑。
We'd been on the road for a little more than an hour when we stopped at a farmer's market. Inside an open air pavilion, a woman offered complimentary plates of hummus served with a corn and black bean salad, so we each accepted one and took seats on a bench.
我们在路上行驶了一个多小时后，在一个农贸市场停了下来。在一个露天亭子里，一位女士提供了免费的鹰嘴豆泥，配上玉米和黑豆沙拉，所以我们每个人都接受了一份并坐在长椅上。
20 years earlier, the most a place like this might have offered was fried okra. Now there was organic coffee, and artisanal goat cheese. Above our heads hung a sign that read "Whispering Dove Ranch."
20年前，像这样的地方最多只能提供炸秋葵。现在有了有机咖啡和工匠山羊奶酪。我们头顶挂着一个标志，上面写着“低语鸽牧场”。
And just as I thought that we might be anywhere, I noticed that the music piped through the speakers was Christian. The new kind, which says that Jesus is awesome.
就在我认为我们可能身处任何地方时，我注意到通过扬声器播放的音乐是基督教音乐。新式的那种，说耶稣很棒。
Hugh brought my father a plastic cup of water. "You OK, Lou?" "Fine, " my father answered.
休给我父亲拿了一杯塑料杯水。“你还好吗，卢？”“还好，”我父亲回答。
"Why do you think she did it?" I asked as we stepped back into the sunlight, for that's all any of us were thinking, had been thinking since we got the news. Mustn't Tiffany have hoped that whatever pills she'd taken wouldn't be strong enough? And that her failed attempt would lead her back into our fold? How could anyone purposefully leave us, us of all people?
“你觉得她为什么这么做？”我们回到阳光下时我问道，因为这就是我们所有人都在想的，自从得到消息后就一直在想。蒂芙尼难道不希望她服用的任何药片都不会那么强烈吗？她失败的尝试会引导她回到我们的怀抱？怎么可能有人会有意离开我们，我们这些人中的所有人？
This is how I thought of it. For though I've often lost faith in myself, I've never lost faith in my family. In my certainty that we are fundamentally better than everyone else. It's an archaic belief, one I haven't seriously reconsidered since my late teens, but still I hold it.
这就是我思考它的方式。因为虽然我经常失去对自己的信心，但我从没失去对家人的信心。我确信我们从根本上比其他人更好。这是一个古老的信念，我从十几岁后期以来就没认真重新考虑过，但我仍然持有它。
Ours is the only club I'd ever wanted to be a member of, so I couldn't imagine quitting. Backing off for a year or two was understandable. But to want out so badly that you'd take your own life?
我们是我想加入的唯一俱乐部，所以我无法想象退出。退出一两年是可以理解的。但想离开到那种程度，以至于你会结束自己的生命？
"I don't know that it had anything to do with us," my father said. But how could it have not? Doesn't the blood of every suicide splash back on our faces?
“我不知道这与我们有什么关系，”我父亲说。但怎么可能没有呢？难道每个自杀者的鲜血不是都溅回了我们的脸上吗？
At the far end of the parking lot was a stand selling reptiles. In giant tanks were two pythons, each as big around as a fire hose. The heat seemed to suit them, and I watched as they raised their heads, testing the screen ceilings.
停车场尽头是一个卖爬行动物的摊位。巨大的水箱里有两条蟒蛇，每条都有消防水管那么粗。热量似乎很适合它们，我看着它们抬起头，试探着屏幕天花板。
Beside the snakes was a low pen corralling an alligator with its mouth banded shut. It wasn't full grown, but perhaps an adolescent, around three feet long and grumpy looking. A girl had stuck her arm through the wire and was stroking the thing's back while it glared, seething.
蛇旁边是一个低矮的围栏，关着一只嘴巴被束缚住的短吻鳄。它还没完全长大，但可能是一只未成年，大约三英尺长，看起来脾气暴躁。一个女孩把手臂伸过金属丝，正在抚摸那东西的背，而它怒视着，怒气冲冲。
"I'd like to buy everything here, just so I could kill it," I said. My father mopped his forehead with Kleenex. "I'm with you, brother."
“我想买下这里的一切，只是为了能杀掉它，”我说。我父亲用纸巾擦了擦前额。“我站在你这边，兄弟。”
When we were young and would set off for the beach, I'd look out the window at all the landmarks we drove by-- the Purina silo on the south side of Raleigh, the Klan billboard-- knowing that when we passed them a week later, I'd be miserable. Our vacation over, now there'd be nothing to live for until Christmas.
当我们年轻并出发去海滩时，我会从窗户看着我们经过的所有地标——罗利南侧的普瑞纳筒仓，三K党的广告牌——知道一周后我们经过它们时，我会感到痛苦。我们的假期结束了，现在直到圣诞节没什么可活的了。
My life is much fuller than it was back then, yet this return felt no different. "What time is it?" I asked Amy. And instead of saying "Who cares?" she said, "You tell me. You're the one with the watch on."
我的生活比那时充实得多，但这种回归感觉没什么不同。“现在几点了？”我问艾米。她没有说“谁在乎？”，而是说，“你自己看吧。你才是戴着手表的那个人。”
At the airport a few hours later, I picked sand from my pockets and thought of our final moments at the beach house I'd bought. I was on the front porch with Phyllis, who had just locked the door, and we turned to see the others in the driveway below us.
几小时后在机场，我从口袋里捡起沙子，想起我们在我买下的海滩别墅里的最后时刻。我和菲莉丝在门廊上，她刚锁上门，我们转过身看到下面车道上的其他人。
"So is that one of your sisters?" she asked, pointing at Gretchen. "It is," I said. "And so are the two women standing on either side of her."
“那是你的姐妹之一吗？”她指着格雷琴问。“是的，”我说。“站在她两边的两个女人也是。”
"Then you've got your brother," she observed. "That makes five. Wow, now that's a big family."
“然后你有你的兄弟，”她观察到。“那加起来五个。哇，那是一个大家庭。”
I looked at the sun-baked cars we would soon be climbing into, furnaces, every one of them, and said, "Yes. It certainly is."
我看着我们很快就要爬进去的被阳光烘烤的汽车，每一辆都是熔炉，说，“是的。确实是。”
David Sedaris is the author of many books, most recently, Let's Explore Diabetes With Owls .
大卫·塞达里斯是许多书的作者，最近的一本是《让我们用猫头鹰探索糖尿病》。
[MUSIC - "USED TO BE" BY BEACH HOUSE]
[音乐 - BEACH HOUSE的《过去》]
[MUSIC - "DAY AT THE BEACH" BY ATLANTIC THRILLS]
[音乐 - ATLANTIC THRILLS的《海滩的一天》]
Our program was produced today by Robyn Semien, with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sarah Koenig, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Brian Reed, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Production help from Alison Davis.
我们的节目今天由罗宾·塞米恩制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格、本·卡尔霍恩、莎拉·凯尼格、米基·米克、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、布莱恩·里德、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克参与。我们的高级制片人是朱莉·斯奈德。制作协助来自艾莉森·戴维斯。
Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon's our production manager. Elise Bergerson's our administrative assistant. Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website.
塞斯·林德是我们的运营总监。艾米丽·康登是我们的制作经理。埃莉斯·伯格森是我们的行政助理。阿德里安娜·马蒂沃维茨负责我们的网站。
Research help today from Michelle Harris. Music help from Damian Graef and Rob Geddis. Special thanks today to Willow Yamauchi, Craig Desson and the Factory Theater in Toronto.
今天研究协助来自米歇尔·哈里斯。音乐协助来自达米安·格拉夫和罗布·格迪斯。今天特别感谢威洛·ヤマウチ、克雷格·德森和多伦多的工厂剧院。
Our website, ThisAmericanLife.Org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
我们的网站，ThisAmericanLife.Org。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
Thanks as always to our show's co-founder Torey Malatia, who remembers meeting Hillary Clinton-- incredible--at some crazy beach party back in the '70s. There she appeared--
一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚，他记得70年代在某个疯狂的海滩派对上遇见希拉里·克林顿——难以置信。她出现在那里——
A completely naked woman. Blond hair, really muscly. Her shoulders looked like she was probably a rafting guide in Colorado.
一个完全赤裸的女人。金色的头发，真的很健壮。她的肩膀看起来像是科罗拉多州的漂流向导。
I'm Ira Glass. Stay warm. Wear a hat. And I'll be back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯。保持温暖。戴上帽子。我下周会回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
[MUSIC - "DAY AT THE BEACH" BY ATLANTIC THRILLS]
[音乐 - ATLANTIC THRILLS的《海滩的一天》]
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。